[Applause]
stamford bridge
home of chelsea one of the six rebel
english teams who'd signed up for the
new league
on the pitch the team were facing
brighton on tuesday night
off it furious negotiations as the club
management
alarmed by the backlash from fans were
said to be drawing up the paperwork to
withdraw from the league
fans gathered in front of the grounds
making their opposition clear
even the team bus prevented from getting
to the stadium these scumbag owners are
putting
their own teams that they've bought into
the super league
so they don't have to earn their way
into the champions league
following chelsea's lead in quitting the
league manchester city
along with spanish side atletico madrid
city's manager gave this damning
assessment of the project
a sport is not a sport when
the relation between the effort and the
success the effort and reward
doesn't exist don't exist so it's not a
sport
so it's not a sport of the success is
already guaranteed
earlier on tuesday at a karma setting in
switzerland
the president of europe's governing body
uefa urged all
12 european teams from england spain and
italy
to think again gentlemen
you made a huge mistake some will say
it is greed others
disdain arrogance flippancy or complete
ignorance
of england's football culture but
actually it doesn't matter the british
prime minister met for crisis talks with
fans groups and officials from england's
football association and the premier
league i think it's
not in the interests of fans it's not in
the interests of
football and prince william president of
the football association
said the league risks damaging the
english game we love
only days after the idea of a super
league first surfaced
it now looks like chelsea fans have got
exactly what they wanted a decision
by top brass in the club to hastily exit
this unpopular project crowds here
have gone from protest to jubilation
meanwhile many of the club's owners and
top officials have remained tight-lipped
real madrid president florentino perez
who is one of the few to publicly defend
the project
designed he said to save soccer
what we want to do is save football so
it can live peacefully for at least the
next 20 years
[Applause]
england's biggest and richest clubs have
faced unprecedented anger from their
fans
and from the remaining 14 teams in
england's premier league
pressure that now appears to have forced
some of the most powerful people in
football
to change their plans leave barca al
jazeera
london